Good morning, John.
I'm glad that you're enjoying the majestic
and exotic Amsterdam so much. But here in
Missoula, Montana we have something that I
don't think that you have in your little apartment
in Amsterdam, and that is video games. I know
that they...have... but I want to talk about
video games today! I've been playing Portal
2 on my gaming channel, and it's super fun.
I've also been playing Lego Harry Potter and
Assassin's Creed. I'm about to finish up Assassin's
Creed, so I'm trying to figure out what I'm
going to do next. I grew up in a different
video game age, and while you, uh, sort of
had control over the Nintendo when it wasn't
filled with poop, I had to play a different
kind of video game because you were bogarting
the grey box.
So I was playing a different sort of game,
a two dimensional game, a DOS sort of game.
Simulation games... that actually simulated
things. And so with the hope that I will educate
people who were not around during this era
and provide a certain amount of nostalgia
for those of us who are old enough to remember
it, I am going to talk today about the best
simulation games of the 1990s.
So Maxis was a company that pretty much created
the simulation game. They started with SimCity,
and then they tried to do everything, and
they ended up doing the Sims which is, I think,
the most popular simulation game of all time
where you get to pretend to be a person! Which
is weird; you would think people would want
to pretend to be something else besides a
person since they get to be a person every
day, but yeah.
So Maxis made SimLife where you got to sort
of create evolutionary biology. And they created
SimAnt where you simulated an ant colony and
got to take over somebody's house. That was
weird. And SimHealth which was a simulation
of America's health care system which, unsurprisingly,
was a nightmare and not at all fun. It wasn't
like "SimSurgery", it was like "SimHMOs."
And then there was one of my favorites which
was SimFarm which is like FarmVille except
actually a simulation of a farm. Like, for
example, if you don't feed your pigs, they
die. You have to borrow money from the bank,
and you can sell your crops on the futures
market. And the only way to get rich is to
plant a cash crop monoculture because you're
a farmer, and that's how it is!
And then there's Sid Meier's Civilization,
a game that has now had five incarnations,
all of them REALLY good. And there's different
ways to "win" the game. You can kill everyone
which is, you know, enjoyable for some people.
Or you can find peace and a strength in a
diverse planet with lots of different people.
Maybe the warlike people will be eradicated.
People who love peace can live together in
harmony!
SimEarth, another Maxis game, was a simulation
of the entire planet, like CO2 levels and
ocean currents. The actual interaction that
you had with the game was pretty limited,
but really, it was just a textbook in the
form of a game which was good for me because
I was a little nerd!
And now I'm going to end with SimCity because,
of course, SimCity and SimCity 2000: best
simulation games of all time! I got SimCity
when I was nine years old, so at that ripe
young age, I got to become the mayor of Heresville,
decide whether I wanted to be a destructive
or benevolent leader. I was always benevolent.
I, I wish I could say I was destructive. I
never... I never do the evil thing in video
games. People who have watched me play Assassin's
Creed are laughing right now. That's because
I get bored with Assassin's Creed and I just
start stabbing people.
I can hardly conceive of the amount of stuff
that I just implicitly know about the world
because of simuliza--SIMULIZATION! That's
the second time I've done that! That's the
second take in which I said "simulization!"
But more than the truth about the world and
the facts that I learned from "simulization"
games-- what I really love about them is that
often there's no winning; there's no goal.
You can't beat SimCity.
Because that's one of the weird things about
life; like, we don't know why--what we're
doing here. We don't know what we're supposed
to do. Different parts of society and different
cultures put different weights on different
things, whether it's having a healthy family
or fancy cars or comparing yourself to your
coworkers or making lots of money. But unless
you're Charlie Sheen, there's no winning.
You never get to beat life. Knowing I get
to decide for myself what success is, that's
one of the most important lessons I ever learned.
And I learned it from playing simulation games
so... fancy that!
John, I know that you were busy playing Nintendo
games while all of this was going on, so I
hope this wasn't too boring for you. Uh, but
yes! That is how I became a nerd!
I'll see you on Friday.